each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
and then later a scientist at the
biomedical engineering department at USC
and the last six years five six years
he's been an assistant professor of
cognitive science at UCSD we've been
working on stochastic optimal control
and bayesian inference to understand how
the brain does sensorimotor integration
and some of the methods he works on are
inspired by biology so it's wonderful to
see what biology has discovered in its
random walk buffeted by natural
selection that help us understand how to
do better math so emo so pleasure to be
here and hello to all the remote
audience so I work on on both biological
and engineering / math side of things
what I'll do today is going to start
with server highlight a few projects
without much detail and then the second
half of the talk I'm going to go into
detail into the latest and greatest
thing that I've been doing hope will
give you both breadth and depth of some
sort I guess most people actually not
here but those of you who here please
feel free to interrupt with questions at
any time I I really like that so the
general framework I work in is
stochastic optimal control what does
that mean you have something that you
want to control in this case it's some
arm but it could be a robot or or even
some sort of virtual agent in some
software environment and it has some
constraints that are imposed by the way
that thing is designed and usually it we
considered it as a stochastic system it
has knowledge both into actuator and in
the sensor loops you can also have
delays so the idea is that if you are if
you're given a body and you're given
some sort of objectives that you want to
accomplish with that body or that
sometimes it's called a planet setting
your control what is the best you
do I suppose you have no constraints on
computation your infinity smart and you
can design the best possible control
system ever how is that thing going to
work and what it's going to look like so
you can show mathematically that the way
you do that is you need to build a base
optimal state estimator that's trying to
figure out what the world is doing and
then take the outputs of that with your
belief states or you could represent
them in some low dimensional weight as
means and covariances let's say and then
put them into a feedback controller
which is basically a mapping from the
estimated state of the world into
instantaneous commands that you sent to
your actuators and then the whole thing
is running the loop of course this
arrows here because you have delays and
noise in your sensory feedback and so if
you want to come up with optimal
estimates of the state of the world and
your body you need to take into account
a copy of the motor commands that you
send to your muscle muscle in biology
that's called an efferent copy it just
means a copy of whatever you sent here
so why would the brain do the best
possible thing well that sort of
evolution is you know you can think of
evolution is a big optimization process
that's making things better and better
in fact if you look at the computational
models of evolution their genetic
algorithms which are basically medical
numerical immunization tend to be
somewhat robust and samples long but
that's what they are and indeed there is
more and more data accumulating that if
you look at the details of biological
movement you can understand those
details from the viewpoint of optimality
so there are a number of high-profile
review paper series recently that you
can check out if you want that summarize
a lot of the experimental evidence for
it and the story usually goes as follows
thank you you can't put a task that you
present to human subjects or some animal
and you figure out what would be the
optimal behavior in that task so it's
for example it's a perceptual task you
know that the organism has some pairs
about what might be going on and there's
some sensory stimuli and you have some
data likelihood and then use Bayes rule
to combine them into a posterior and
then you ask the organism to make
decisions and you see if it goes
according to a pasear and you the answer
is usually
on the motor side you can ask for
example have a task which means which
requires me to take my fingertip to
press that button here so you can write
down a cost function which specifies
what does it mean to perform well ok so
in this case it means well make sure you
press the button at the end and you want
to put to put things like be lazy or
don't forgive your messes so when you
build costs of sensible cost functions
like this and then you solve an optimal
control problem and you look at the
details of the movement they tend to
agree with data very nicely so in this
talk I'm going to highlight a couple of
examples of this from my lab but I
should emphasize up there are many other
thing you can look at this review paper
see if you're interested now of course
everyone in engineering knows that being
optimal is good and everyone would love
to accomplish that but the question is
how do you pull it off and if you have a
complicated thing that you want to
control let's say bipedal robot that's
supposed to walk around and pick up your
coffee captain you know put it in the
dishwasher how do you actually know what
is the best thing to do in the brain may
be smart enough to know it but how do we
as engineers build a system that does
that and of course we don't know if we
knew we would have robots going around
serving coffee because you know the
hardware problems are mostly solved it's
just we don't know how to control the
robot that's why they're not walking
around serving coffee and it's
convenient that the brain had already
has a solution because by observing it
closely and trying to figure out what
sort of algorithms and shortcuts it uses
we might be able to come up with tricks
that tell us how to better control in in
artificial systems as well as understand
the brain better so I'll tell you about
a couple of properties of optimal
control systems that may be somewhat
non-obvious and they seem to be very
relevant to biology so the first time is
something that we found a while ago and
called the minimal intervention
principle so what that says is if you
have a redundant task redundant ask
means that you have lots of degrees of
freedom like all my degrees of vision of
the arm I want the fingertip to go here
but there are all these things that can
happen don't really affect the task
performance
and similarly as I'm moving towards this
button my arm can go this way or that
way it doesn't really matter the bottom
doesn't care how i get there i saw
almost everything you ever do it with
your body is a redundant testing have
all these degrees of freedom now if you
look at the classical ways to control
mechanical systems with things like PID
control what you do is you pick some
reference trajectory in advance and that
reference trajectory is one out of
infinitely many ways to accomplish the
task and that you do that in some
planning phase and then in the planning
phase you resolve all the redundancy
basically and then you have a pretty
dumb control system that is just
basically and track this reference
trajectory and exempting pushes you away
or you have same modeling errors so you
your body doesn't activities from the
way you thought and you deviate the
controller basically pushes you back
okay so here's a simple the simplest
possible model redundant task supposed
to have two state variables x1 and x2
and the task is to keep their sum equals
some target battle so if you plot them
in state space X 1 versus X 2 so the
state of the system is a point somewhere
in this plane you have one direction
where x1 plus x2 very so you don't want
fluctuations here there's another
direction where it doesn't matter what
you do because here x1 plus x2 is
constant now the traditional approach to
control will say well pick a point in
this space and inter in a planning phase
and then no matter what happens just
push the system towards that point okay
so if you were to visualize the control
law as a some sort of vector field in
that space which basically takes a point
and pushes it somewhere the traditional
controller would be something that serve
all the arrows point towards the center
turns out the optimal thing to do is not
that instead the optimal thing to do is
to push towards this manifold of
redundant states okay so these are the
actions of the optimal controller shown
here why is that the optimal thing to do
well turns out there are two reasons one
is that obviously you're going to save
energy and so if if you push towards
this point which is pushing towards that
point obviously this takes less energy
to get you here and energy is very
important to both biological and
artificial systems like you don't want
to run out of battery prematurely the
other thing you use
you improve his accuracy it turns out
there is so that that's a bit not
obvious so if you watch biological
systems you very quickly find out that
the variability in their movement scales
with the amount of effort they exert ok
so the stronger you push the more noisy
your muscles become in fact you've
always experienced that if you want to
touch something big like a table can
make a very quick movement but if i want
to touch something small like the
pointer i kind of have to slow down and
so there's a natural speed accuracy
trade-off ok so why do you slow down if
you want more acuras the reason you're
slow down is because fast movement
requires big control signals the control
signals are associated with more noise
which is sore generated by your brain
and that makes you in a cure ok so the
noise in the in the motor system is
signal dependent it basically scales
with the amount of the sea and so
smaller controls are not only going to
save you energy but they're also going
to make you more accurate again this is
shown actually here so this he lives
shows you what will happen to that
system if you act on it with this
controller that's pushing towards this
manifold and it has the signal dependent
note that's pushing it around ok so if
you look at the fluctuations in the in
that state of that system you're going
to find the covariance he lives that
serve elongated like that so you have
more variability in the directions that
are not relevant and less variability in
the direction that you care about if you
act on this with a controller that's
just pushing towards the middle you're
going to get a sort of a more circular
thing that looks like that so if you
compare a classical control law which
will give you the circle an optimal
control 0 which will give you the
ellipse what you find is that the
optimal controller can actually do
better in the things that matter but
only by allowing variability in things
that don't matter it so the point is
that if you want to be accurate you
can't control too much you have to
sacrifice your booty to controlling the
things that are not relevant the lots of
illustrations of that in behavioral data
so here let me show you to them so here
this person was asked to point to target
zone on his body and he's holding this
wooden thing it has 22 tips 1 and 2 and
there's a sensor here distracting the
position orientation of the thing ok so
he does that repeatedly and then if you
collection of movements you can ask how
variable are the movements at different
points along the movement and so we can
just summarize the data so this is the
path length of the movement going from
zero to one hundred percent okay and you
see two things one is that tip one which
is sort of the working tip is controlled
more accurately than tip 2 so on this
axis is the traditional variance okay so
even though this is sort of symmetric
from for mechanical parts the brain
actually cares about one tip and allows
the other one to plug check the other
thing you see is that the variability of
both of them is reduced towards the end
of the movement where you you have to
hit the target but the rest of time is
kind of loud to fluctuate here's a
similar example so here this person has
to go around the shelter hit this target
and later that target is going to jump
around and probe the feedback control
all the person before now she's sitting
stationary look at the variability of
the movements you again you see these
are more dispersion here than towards
the end so that's a very
well-established experimental finding an
answer degrees very nice dude what you
would expect from an optimal control now
if you look closely here you realize
something interesting so what does it
mean for controller to push towards some
manifold well it means that the
controller has access to these
independent control variables u 1 and u
2 so what they do is basically they push
the two state variables independent so
the controller can choose to control
these two muscles let's say
independently but it doesn't want to
instead what wants to do is couple them
and and set them equal to something
which in this case is some function of
these state variables so that that falls
from the fact that these arrows are
parallel now this idea of controlling a
highly redundant system by coupling the
degrees of freedom the very old idea in
biology goes back almost a century and
the idea is called the motor synergy so
synergy is like creating a high level
control knob that you can tweak and then
that has some distributed action on all
the low level degrees of freedom and if
you get the right high level control
knobs you can simplify your life a lot
and still accomplish directing here's an
illustration of that point so here is a
more complicated example this
the server model system it has three
point masses that can slide at slide up
and down these are muscle like actuators
that can both pull and push that have
followed them the task that will give
this thing is to make this top point
mass go to some targets at certain point
in time so this is time this is the
position of the three points and we
specify those targets and we build the
optimal controller for that thing using
sort of linear quadratic methods okay
what you see is that the top point mass
is controlled very accurately this
catches of fluctuating so now the
control system is a mapping from
estimated states to actions so this
system has about like 12 state variables
and five actual such a 12 to five
matrix-12 by five minutes so it could
have full rank if it wants to but if you
look at that matrix it turns out it
actually has very low rank one or two so
you can just do singular value
decomposition and find out what it is
and then when you do that you can you
can decompose this optimal feedback
control law in you can represent as a
linear network like that and so what it
does it takes the inputs which are the
raw sort of states like the lengths of
all these guys in the velocities of the
point mats etc and then it compresses
them into some lower dimensional space
where it wants to do control so this is
the space of things that actually matter
or the task okay so you can take a dive
script compression then it must buys
them by some feedback gains within that
reduce space and then it expands them
again and then sends them to their
masters and for situations where we can
solve for the control law we can look at
all the structure these matrices so for
example this is creating two so-called
motor synergies so each column of this
says I tweak this control knob here's
how I'm going to affect the five muscle
so I'm going to suppress those to
inactivate those two and leave this
dialog so you get interesting structures
like for example for this thing the
optimal controller doesn't actually need
muscle to so it leaves it alone even
though it's there so what this this
example show is that if you have a
redundant task and you do the hard work
of finding the best possible way to
control the system you're going to
discover that your solution has
hierarchical structure
so it maps things into some hollow space
and that stings there and push number
okay well if you know that in advance
questions can you take advantage of that
knowledge and can you sort of build in
that hierarchical structure a priori so
then your optimization algorithm doesn't
have to take forever searching for
something that you could have guessed to
start with okay so so this is exactly in
the scope of what we do so there is so
this idea of motor synergies is
basically about hierarchical control and
that's one of the most powerful and
often use theoretical ideas in motor
control that and optionally kisser too
big theoretical things that that people
talk about yeah that doesn't hurt so I
was referring to actual the experimental
field of motor control where the people
like in a geologist and and physical
therapist standing like this is what you
recording a lot of movements okay so or
robotically so in robotics that that's
another story yes yes okay so the Sun
the neural anatomy is clearly
hierarchical in the sense that you have
fast feedback loops going through the
spinal cord and then you have a signals
are going to cortex but the spinal cord
actually does something before the rest
of the brain has time to respond so so
it's very clear yeah but except context
is really complicating so I have a
circle we have multiple cortical areas
you have the basal ganglia oh that's who
knows what so actually both the system
is not
hierarchical it's it has a clearly
defined low level which is a spinal cord
once you go beyond that it sort of
becomes a mosaic of things that have a
loose echo relationship but it's not
known who that's what in terms of this
idea of dimensionality reduction you
know is it the case that they're
actually a small number of control knobs
at you tweak there is nice data from
middle booty slap and also Simon give
their own colleagues stimulating the
spinal cords are like frogs and cats and
such and showing that no matter where
you stimulate you actually elicit one of
a very small number of force fields so
basically the design of God has a few a
small number of dynamic states that
wants to go to and no matter how you
stimulate you just goes to one of them
and in frogs they found four of them for
example Emilio beach Ian company some
publishing scientist in the 90s in in
motor cortex people have looked been
looking for evidence of this kind of
massive synergy so it record from
neurons and and correlate with muscles
and see other correlation partners
clustered in some way the evidence there
is very hard to interpret because once
you go to places that tends to be
complicated so under when you talk about
individual neurons it's it's hard to to
trace it to taste this it's probably
because you know the abstract state
variables that we talked about are not
represented by a single neuron but by
large collections of neurons so you
wouldn't recognize this even if you saw
it on the behavioral side what people do
is is basically collect a large data set
of behavior including muscle activity
and do some sort of pca or non-linear
dimensionality reduction and you find
that the actual output of the brain is
very low dimensional much lower than it
had to be going to robotics people have
been using these things for a while so
perhaps the most salient work is awesome
and creative and colleagues from from
Stanford so there's something called
operational space control and the idea
there is that it's actually quite
similar to this so you have some robotic
system you decided you want to control
the end effector what you do is you
express the inertia and Coriolis forces
and everything in end effector space
and then you you actually cancel them
you do something like feedback
linearization so now once you make your
hand behave like a disembodied point
masters just floating around and then
you can easily control it these things
tend to all right so so if some so you
have you about control in that abstract
space or something push you can push
back but if something happens in the now
space then things become more
complicated there is something called
the feedback linearization which is one
of the few systematic ways to treat
nonlinear systems and and that shows up
there is so there's something called
input output feedback linearization
which is kind of hierarchical and leaves
this now space where things can happen
so actually the next slide is sort of
along these lines so so here's the
general so a method that we developed
and it's related to this robotics things
that i'd mention so have a thing you
want to control instead of having one
monolithic control system going to break
it up in say two so have a low level
control it takes the state it produces
some abstract high level state which is
some function of X and then somehow they
will control the sides what to do it
sends a high level command signal and
then this guy is just a translator
basically so the job of this guy is not
to execute any specific task but instead
to serve augment the plant and turn it
into a different plant so body with a
little bit of brain attached to it may
be easier to control than just the body
itself okay so now the high level
control can think of the brain the body
plus a little bit of brain as one big
sore body with different state and then
that can be control serve on a high
level mathematically the way you do that
is you write down the dynamics of the
plant and you have some cost function
the construction site we use tend to
have a energy costs which basically
tells you to be lazy and some sort of
state dependent cost which tells you
what you want to do it could be anything
and then you define this high-level
stake and differentiate that and you get
the dynamics of the high level state
which depends on this Jacobian matrix
and then you specify what you would like
the dynamics of the high level to be you
actually have the freedom to do so and
then you match those two and you find
the you that sort of such size this
constraint and at the same time
minimize this energy so using energy
minimization as a regular Iser 40 post
problem and you actually can find this
low level controller in closed form we
have a robotics paper on that which
deals with complicated cases for soup
the pseudo-inverse doesn't exist and you
can look at the details well one
interesting trick that that's probably
very important actually in many other
areas is if you're teaching up a
dynamical system in continuous time and
suppose your controls are things like
forces or even the derivatives of forces
because muscles act like low-pass filter
so you actually controlling the
derivative force and and the high level
is supposed to be something like let's
say position so you want to do first
order control so in other words if you
have a mismatch in the order of the
derivatives so the low level is a third
order thing and the high level is a
first order plant how do you do this
translation so if you look at it
instantaneously in continuous time the
answer is well you can't however if you
imagine the system is being a discrete
time system then in a finite time step
the third derivatives can actually
integrate twice and affect your first
derivative so you can actually take
advantage of that to bridge the gap
between dynamic orders of the model and
we have ways of doing that yes yeah
fitts law is ficks law is very nicely
predicted by this optimal control models
by the way yeah there's a paper by
Harrison Wahlberg 98 published in nature
which has beautiful models showing four
arms and also for I movements showing
that basically you minimize endpoint
errors under this signal dependent noise
and if you put target different
distances and scale the size you get
fits all perfectly out of it you even
get the little deviations from fitts law
which it's not exactly linear so for
those of you who don't know if it's law
is the relationship between the
amplitude of a movement and the duration
of a movement and the size of the target
you're trying to head yeah so there was
this iterative like stochastic iterative
Corrections model which is effectively a
stochastic optimal control model in
discrete time so it says you know make a
movement ballistically see where it
lands and then compute the optimal
correction so these continuous novels
are sort of doing the same boat but in a
more realistic way because the brain
doesn't have this ballistic phase is
followed by another ballistic moment
thank you all right so so we've been
playing with this with this medicine
will shown that for reasonably simple
systems where we can actually compute
the optimal solution independently the
solutions that we get from this match
very closely we've also been applying
them to more complicating so here's a
biomechanical model of an armed with
seven degrees of freedom and bunch of
muscles like 20 of them these ghostly
yellow blue things show wrapping objects
so the way you model mess as usual is we
want tomorrow how they're pulling
directions change as they are moves
around and that's really complicated
actually that makes the control over by
mechanical system much harder than
control the robot because think of a
robot where the older motors are so
floating around and changing the joints
on which they operate that's basically
what your body does all that so you have
a model of this muscles also has some
interesting properties which is that
muscles don't produce force in
proportion to how much you activate them
but instead they're very sensitive to
the length and the dorset e of the
matter so this shows your model that's
fit to lots of data so you calculate a
muscle at a maximum level the force that
you get from it is not constant but
depends a lot on the length and the
ghost of the machine actually can go all
the way down to zero for physiological
length and lost so for example evacuate
my biceps and I'm moving my arm very
fast somewhere in the middle of that
motion the biceps is basically unable to
produce force even though its maximal
activate so you put all these things put
it in in a model and then try to control
this thing here's the task where we ask
this arm to go to some point at high and
then go down and do some punch
mass-circulation that distinct computer
quickly and into the job this is
somewhat preliminary but but it works
very efficiently these are these are
massive activations that yeah by the
thing yeah we've tried just the you know
plane optimal control methods that are
among the fastest actually the use of
iterated linear quadratic Gaussian
approximations
it's sort of the equivalent of second
order minimization methods applied
adapted to control here in and these
things work well for in low dimensional
systems with maybe six ten state
variables but when you go to something
as complex like that they tend to break
down you seem to need well this is the
dist or perhaps the same right i mean
suppose you have some horrendously
complicated immunization landscape and
your algorithm pens to get stagnant
local minima now if you restart it you
know 10 billion times you probably find
the fastest solution but but then the
amount of computation sort of scales
exponentially with with the
dimensionality of this so when one
reason for pushing this is not not only
to build models of how humans know but
also to fix things so so here's some
technology that you probably know about
these are implantable muscle stimulators
developed by jerry logan company at USC
so you can actually plan these things in
muscles the wireless they just sit there
and then you power them remotely with a
coil that you can wear in the sleeve of
your jacket and you can also control the
remote so you can tell them what to do
and they stimulate the muscles and you
can implant a lot of these so with this
technology you can effectively take over
somebody's arm either paralyzed and so
then questions who what do you do with
our math you take over it you know how
you control such thing yes simulating
the message so masses can be stimulated
electrically and they produce okay so
muscles will stay alive as long as
somebody activates them now in that so
what happens often in in stroke in
various disorders you you know
occasionally use function electric
stimulation of muscles to keep the
muscles a lot if you don't need a nurse
to keep a master like you need some
activation of the muscle otherwise it
would atrophy but if you if you
stimulated electrically that's good
enough the nerve doesn't have
motor neuron she still need the law of
our connection with special neuron
whatever's whatever the neuron is
sharing with the muscle to muscle
library and if it's not apply to the
upper motor neuron lesion spectacle of
more Oregon but the lower motor neurons
are maintaining the connection you know
but I mean this is used for example
there people with spinal cord injury
where the nerves are basically not
sending any signals or or maybe they're
saying there's this year so so so we
just love you you can you can send
activations to the masses and the
question is what activations using
another so this is the electrode
acceptance sir so these things are
biologically compatible you inject them
in a muscle did some connective tissue
grows and keeps them there and they
don't move around Gerry Lopez them
injected in his cats for like over 10
years now and the cats are perfectly
happy and they're also injected in a
number of humans and no no one has had
any problems with
so so there's this other thing which is
this has been generating a lot of
excitement in the brain computer
interface world so you can implant
multi-electrode array xin cortex usually
motor cortex and then you can do some
real real time spike sorting and use
that to predict what the animal intends
to do with this hand and then people
have gotten reasonably successful so you
can get a monkey to move our sort of
virtual cursor by thinking about it or
whatever its brain is doing now it's
okay to move a hand but you really want
to control all these muscles in order
they're going to move the hand right and
there is no way you're going to decode
them the intended massive activations
but looking at the brain because
recording the intended hand movement is
already to complicate so it'll be nice
to have a method which can map in real
time sort of intended hand motions in 3d
to mass evacuations that are actually
going to produce those motions and it
doesn't have to be perfectly optional it
just has to be something that it doesn't
succeed patient patience too much and so
and so something like this that can very
efficiently compute plausible mass
activations is either it's a good good
thing so we're hoping to apply it in
that domain see how we doing with time
this is going to be some are we here let
me show you one more experimental
finding which is kind of interesting to
illustrate interesting things that fall
out of optional control so here's an
experiment last people to make a
movement to some target you know on a
table this is a target and then during
the movement target can jump randomly
either up or down okay and you can
predict the jumping direction that's
random but you can use visual feedback
to correct during the movement okay and
so the target can jump in different
times the one or two or three hundred
milliseconds into the movement so he
jumps early enough you may complete
correction that goes to target but turns
out jump sort of late you make an
incomplete correction you stop
before hitting the target so and you can
do serve careful control so to show that
this is not simply due to lack of time
what I mean by that is if you ask people
to do just that movement from here to
here in the remaining time here they can
actually do it in they still have plenty
of time so something sort of more
unusual is going on now when we first
saw that we thought about this is really
bad for our models because the optimal
thing cannot possibly be to make an
error what turns out that is something
so here's an optimal control model that
reproduces this result very nicely and
this is some more statistics that we
don't have to go into so why does that
happen so we found that by analyzing
this model turns out that there is a
trade-off between accuracy and stability
and it's easy to understand sort think
about simple physics so supposed to help
mass on a spring and you want to bring
it to some point the spring is like a
positional feedback game if there is
viscosity in the system that's like the
velocity feedback game ok so this you
can think of these optimal controllers
as being some sort of having some sort
of time-varying stiffness and damping
built into them now if you want this
match to really go to a target you want
a very stiff thing right so that's going
to bring the mass so thank you but then
it's going to make it obsolete right so
and and so that you sacrificed ability
if you want to make the things stable
you need to put in app damping but
that's going to tend to cause under
shoots and slowness in get into a target
so it's a fundamental trade-off and the
neural system is subject to the same
thing so now if you if you look if you
build the optimal control over this
behavior and you look at the different
feedback gain this is a function of time
so KP is the springiness of decision as
the position feedback gain K V is the
velocity feedback game and this a is
particularly as force feedback what you
see is that the the system has enough
feedback gain for position errors early
on but then this thing goes to zero and
the reason is that if you have if you
have a spring constant that's large
towards the end of the movement here you
end up oscillating and you don't want to
do that and so the optimal thing to do
is to reduce your sensitivity to
positional errors towards the end of the
movement sorry gusta
and so that system produces these
undershirts if you perturb the target in
the last minute and that's what people
do so that analysis leads to a simple
prediction which is that if you didn't
have to stop at the target so suppose
instead of just stopping somewhere I'm
supposed to hit a target that's on the
table and tables going to absorb the
impact I can't oscillate so it really
that if you put people in that situation
that this effect should sort of
disappear and so that's what we've done
here so this robot now you make a
movement draw what is going to move the
target either left or right and we also
program sort of variable impedance into
the robot so in one condition it's very
hard so you can actually should be
targeting it's going to absorb impact in
another condition is kind of very touchy
and it's fragile and if you hit it too
hard it's going to run away and pretend
that it's broken and you're not supposed
to that and so the stop condition is the
one where you're supposed to stop the
hip condition is the condition where you
can hit it and we can look at that
altitude and we find that indeed it so
it basically goes away when you're
allowed to hit the thing and we can
model that carefully so this is an
example where you know you know it's not
very exciting to look at those graphs
but but if you really want to go after
behavioral effects there well quantified
you have to do psychophysics that looks
somewhat boring but you know that's the
way it descends you have to do simple
things and it's a new station that has
some unknown obvious properties fall out
of optimal control skip this mmm one
thing we're doing now is instead of
doing all the math here we're replacing
all the map with a big recurrent neural
network so has the same inputs as a
bayesian estimator has the same motor
commands as the thing that goes to a
muscle high level things to tell you
what to do like where is a target or how
much time you have etcetera and I will
have a well-defined movement cost and
then we're training this network such
that when its motor commands go through
the body it's going to make good
movement so it's somewhat unusual
paradigm for training neural network
it's unusual in that you don't specify
that what the outputs of the network
should do but you're specifying the
desired effect after these help to
filter through something and the whole
network is in this feedback loop so you
can define you can modify the back
propagation
the time algorithm to back propagate
gradients through arbitrary dynamical
systems like an arm and then you contain
it surprisingly efficiently actually I
need to show it approximates feedback
control walls very well and then once
you do that then you can go into the
network and look at the details of the
neuronal activity and compare it to
neurophysiological results from people
starting motor cortex so not going to go
through those details but basically you
get so this is the time into a movement
this is the direction in which the Armos
asked to move and this is the activity
of the 60 neurons into network and you
get things that look rather complicated
and if you were to look at them very
closely you'll find a lot of
similarities with physiological data but
when I'm going to drag here also doing a
number of other things like motion
capture so we develop a system where you
can put a bunch of markers on a hand or
an arm whatever and then it's going to
track the joint angles but it's also
trying to estimate how big the different
segments of the body are android the
markets are attached the reason you want
to do that is because you can never
place the markers exactly where you
intended and even if you do they can
drift so it's important to treat both
leases and notes okay so what we do is
we basically build a estimator that's
you can think of it as an improved
extended Kalman filter and the state
that is estimating has both these
rapidly varying quantities third joint
angles and the slowly varying quantities
slide where the sensors are attached so
it estimates both it's doing both
self-calibration and tracking and you
build these kinematic trees to describe
the thing and it was really why's that
you on my website and people can
download it if they mean so this shows
you consistency of estimation so what
we've done here is with we have to
movement sequences of one minute each
and they're about 40 constant parameters
are supposed to be estimated they have
to do the dimensions of the hand and the
placement of these things and this shows
you the first estimate of all these
constants versus the second Testament
and even though you only have a short
movement sequence that's actually not
very rich the person is kind of wiggling
their fingers a little bit you get very
consistent things this shows you how the
generative model that with it the base
of the predicted sensor measurements
agree with the actual so so to sit alone
it can be used safely as far as I can
tell
we're using it this is a collaboration
we're starting with a couple of people
including the Optimates over here so the
goal is to figure out how to control
hand basically so yoke has been building
these and triple metric hands that
really cool and they're back data by now
also collaborating with DNA by
University of British Columbia who is
building this amazingly elaborate by
mechanical models with all the tendons
sliding on the bone surfaces etc we also
collaborating with Francisco Villa
requires who does some nasty things like
stick needles into people's hands and
guide a wire electrode into all the
muscles that control one finger say and
assuming you don't faint during the
setup procedure then they can look at
the exact muscle tivity of your index
finger say when you're doing things they
also do things like take cadaver hands
and attach them to force sensors and
pull with various nodes on the tendons
and do system identification so this guy
is really serious about understanding
the hem we're hoping to that some of our
control methods also building our own
little robot which is going to be fully
back terrible so ladies that you mount
mother's very close to joints and then
you put a cable like that so it's a
cable guy so don't know yours or timing
belt or anything the reason you don't
want such things is because you know
biological motion is fully compliant now
if you relax your muscles i can push
your arm is going to work like a
pendulum and industrial robots don't do
that they're not believable because of
the older friction in stiction in the
gears basically and so the idea is to
make this modules in which basically has
like want agree freedom like that and
one like that and one like that and once
you have that then we can either have a
small walking item on that box or we can
turn it upside down in August and we
have that we have a hand that can
manipulate things so we're getting into
okay so this was just an brief overview
of a bunch of projects yes please how do
we sense force without we haven't fully
decided yet so we are I mean one could
put so there's going to be a tendon like
thing going here you could put a force
sensor here you're actually this going
to have very low friction like these
things have la première and I think you
can
is put a force sensor here to detect
touch with the environment and we
probably will probably have to do
haven't decided that yet so my students
are building that as we speak hopefully
okay so what I want to do now how much
fun we should I talk what starts kind of
late like 15-20 minutes okay good okay
okay so the next thing I'll do is show
you some math but I think it's very
interesting man it's worth looking at
the idea is to reformulate stochastic
optimal control problems in a way that
makes them easier to solve so I've been
telling how long that I sort of solve
the problem but really I solve it using
either low dimensional systems where I
can do brute force method or high
dimensional systems where I use linear
or quadratic approximations and then of
these are viable for for the kinds of
things that we want to do so questions
can you find a large enough class of
nonlinear and even discrete systems
where the problem becomes easier and
I've been able to do that and basically
I've been able to reduce the problem to
a linear eigenvalue problem for very
large class of systems and so that
allows you to do things like approximate
shortest paths in a graph with arbitrary
precision by solving a linear algebra
problem or also markov decision
processes or continuous control problems
by solving linear differential equations
and so i'll show you how some of that
works that there's a preprint on my
website if you want to look at the
details and kind of thing i should go to
all them here so I'll subdue a discrete
case and just want to introduce the
terminology that's normally used and
then I'll show you how to modify the
problem okay so have some state space X
that these discrete States the actions
you that you can take a different state
or controls the same thing have some
transition probabilities so you can
state X and choose control you you have
a certain probability of going to
statewide so this is called the markov
decision
process we have some cost you're going
to pay that depends on where you are and
what action you picked and visit you
want to minimize the sum of those things
you can define the cumulative
performance in many ways i discounted
reward or average cost per step or
whatever i'm going to work with one of
them and show your results for other
things and now the key quantity that you
work with in optimal control is this
thing called the optimal value function
the optimal value function is a notion
of long-term performance says you stay
started state eggs and you infinitely
smart and you behave optimally from now
on how much cost you can expect to
accumulate and as you if you know that
you can basically act greedily with
respect to it and you find optimal
actions very quickly and so a lot of
optimal control in the reinforcement
learning and dynamic programming and
basing decision theory and such have to
do with computing that function
basically in things like chess what
people do is a lot of chess experts get
together and try to figure out what that
function should be using various
securities ok so we satisfy something
called the bellman equation which is
very easy to understand it says that
this optional value function is the
minimum of our possible controls of the
instantaneous cost you're going to pay
plus the expected value of the next
state that you're going to find yourself
that's sort of an obvious consistency
condition and that's the basis of most
methods for optimal control dynamic
programming or reinforcement learning
now if you look at that equation it's
not really an equation because it has
this unsolved minimization in it so it's
a way to characterize the function but
it's a horribly nonlinear and
non-monotonic etc so it's very impatient
so now I'm going to show you how you can
define a class of problems where this
minimization can be performed an
elliptically in closed form and so once
you get rid of that then we're going to
get a self-consistency for v which is
stare at your algebraic equation and
then we're going to discover that the
resulting equation is in fact linear so
it's very easy to sew ok so here's what
we're going to do we're going to modify
the notion of what it means to control
something so maybe it's easier to
explain that with a picture suppose you
you have three possible states you can
go to so it's a little graph you can go
to three states 120 okay now in a
stochastic system you're the actions
that you pick correspond to transition
probabilities so let's say the action
one in quotes means that you have high
probability of going to state 1 and low
probabilities to go into the air to
States similarly for 20 now you can
think of those as the opponents in this
simplex of possible probability
distributions so this is just a triangle
in this positive quadrant of the space
every point here is normalized probably
now so what this picture shows you is
that traditional formulation of control
is a has a lot of constraints in it you
know you arbitrarily pick that those
three points are the only ones that are
allowed and that gave you some discrete
optimization problem and discrete
optimization problems are hard to solve
if you turned it into a continuous
optimization bro and then you have hope
for solving so that's what we're going
to instead of allowing only those three
points we're going to allow everything
on the simplex so now the actor or the
controller can basically choose the
transition probabilities of the system
and completely override the system
dynamics if it won't however it's going
to pay a price for doing that and the
price is going to be like an energy
costs so the more you interfere with the
bass lines or passive dynamics of the
system the more of an energy costs
you're going to pay okay so we're going
to define the baseline dynamics as being
some probability it's at some point in
this simplex called T bar and this says
if we don't act at all what is the
system going to do on its own and that's
P bar and then if we act well we can act
in any way we wish but we're going to
bed price the price is shown by this
color plot here so it's basically kill
the divergence between the baseline
dynamics and whatever you choose to act
so the further away you deviate the more
work price you pay so this is formalized
here so this transition probability so
probability of going from X to Y given
action you now you becomes a whole
vector of real numbers as a positive
symbol and you just evaluate that vector
in the next state we're going to impose
the constraint that
if the plastic the dynamics cannot take
you from X to Y then the control cannot
do that either and that's important
because suppose I want I have an agent
that's supposed to go to some mace and
go to a target if I allow the agent to
teleport itself to a target that that's
no good right so i have to constrain it
to only go to neighboring states that's
the idea of this and then this action
cost is going to be whatever cost you
want on the state plus the KL divergence
between the probability you choose to
act on n and is based on dynamics and
kyo divergences expected value of the
log probability ratio ok so so turns out
we cannot solve this problem in closed
form I'm not actually going to go
through the nation so we're going to
skip out the black step in the middle
and you can look at the slides if you
want just going to tell you what happens
so this is our bellman equation you're
minimizing over all possible use call
instantaneous cost plus expected value
of the cost for the next state and if
you look at that math basically what
happens is that you turn that into
minimization over KO divergences and kel
divergence is this conveniently convex
thing which has a global minimum when
two things are equal and so that's why
you can solve this minimization in
closed form and what you get is that the
optimal action or the optimal control is
has a very simple expression it's
basically the passive dynamics waited by
the exponent of the optional value
function okay so this is so if you think
of optimal value function V as energy
this is something like a weighted Gibbs
distribution like if this was uniform BB
exactly give distribution with optimal
value function being energy ok and then
the bellman equation no longer has
minimization in it and it's just this
view of X is equal to instantaneous cost
plus log of sine of X of these value
functions and neither algebra is pretty
simple but we don't have time for it so
so now we basically got rid of the
minimization we have a closed form
solution for the optimal controls given
the optimal value function so now if we
can find the optimal value function
we're in business and that function now
satisfies the self consistency condition
based this being go to this which
doesn't have any
furthermore you look closely you see
that i have this exponent here i have
this log so if i exponentiate this whole
equation i'm going to get the exponent
of V here explanation is the exponent is
going to cancel this log and I have the
exponent to be here okay so this thing
looks nonlinear but in fact it is linear
in the exponent of be okay so we can now
define this exponentially transformed
optimal value function it's going to be
called the zero X which is just this
term okay it's given here and then in
terms of this new function see the
bellman equation becomes linear so 0 X
has to be equal to this exponentiated
state cost then you sum over the passive
dynamics of that see this is of course
just an expectation operator make sure
you're summing over the probability of
all possible next States okay so this we
can write it in vector notation so you
can put all the states into a big column
vector you can put these guys into a big
diagonal matrix call it Q and and and
you can put all these guys into a big
square matrix called P bar and then the
optimal value function satisfies this
linear equation so basically you're
looking for the largest eigen vector of
Q times P and your guarantee that is
going to have eigenvalues one okay so
such things can be solved very
efficiently especially when this is
sparse matrix with things like the
powerman so basically do you do this
simple minded iteration it converges
exponentially in the rate of convergence
is given by the second largest angle
value of this thing so the standard ok
so this summarizes the result for what I
just said you can formulate the control
problem in other ways so you can ask
infinite horizon discounted cost get a
similar thing but the elements of this
vector now raised to the power of this
count actor you can have an infinite
horizon average cost per stage and what
you get here is something similar so
again an eigenvalue problem except now
the eigenvalues are not here it used to
be one here you don't know what it is
you have to find it still largest
eigenvalue and then the average cost
happens to be a negative log of them you
can also have a finite horizon with a
given final cost and you go backwards in
time and it becomes a recursion so all
the traditional formulations of optimal
control can be handled and give you
simple
system so let me give you a couple
examples of how you can use this so the
first thing we're going to do is we're
going to develop something like you
learning algorithm in reinforcement
learning the idea of Q learning is you
have an agent it can sample the
environment it doesn't have a model and
yet it wants to act optimally okay so
how can you learn to do that so remember
this is the bellman equation you came up
with so we want to compute this Z and it
tells you how to form an online learning
algorithm for zero because this just an
expectation you replace it to a sampling
estimate so you have some Z hat which is
your approximation and then you mix your
old approximation with the new
approximation the new approximation is
given by whatever this thing is okay so
that's a very simple-minded learning
algorithm you can speed it up using
importance sampling as with most
sampling algorithms here's a good world
we're supposed to go here and there are
some obstacles it's a comparison of
q-learning tube to different flavors one
with random sampling the other one
speeding up with a greedy policy and
this is the z learning especially if you
look at the fast version of here it's
it's much faster than this like this is
converge these guys going to take a
while to get there so I should emphasize
it's not at all surprising that it works
much faster than cooler because we did a
lot of work analytically and we have
we're getting a lot of mileage out of it
to learning is trying to solve a bigger
and more unstructured problem and of
course it's having hard time here's how
you can approximate shortest paths in in
graphs using this thing so suppose you
have a graph and you build an indicator
variable D XY which says if notes x and
y are connected switch 1 or 0 now we're
going to define the passive dynamics as
a random walk on the graph so
probability of go into action why if you
don't act it's just random walk so you
can otherwise by the number of outgoing
edges you define some terminal states
where the cost of being there is 0 and
then all other states have some constant
cost ok so the setting is that if you're
in a non terminal state you pay costs
see and then once you get to terminal
stage
happy and you don't pay a cost any more
ok so the minim the value function
obviously is going to be the length of
the shortest path times seeing plus
whatever you paid for the actions or
these controls you know that they're
discal divergences ok and now the trick
is that I can make see as large as I
want while the control costs are bounded
of these scale divergencies are bounded
ok so now if I / seen like shown here in
the limited very large see that's going
to recover exactly the solution of the
shortest path problem because these
extra costs are going to drop and yet
for every setting of see I can solve two
things just by solving a largest
eigenvalue problem so it's faster than
things like this this algorithm for
example of course it is an approximation
because I cannot set C to infinity so I
have to live with some finite value C
cannot make too large because I have
these e to the negative seedings and
numerically these things are going to go
to 0 if I set C too large but there is a
convenient region of see where various
types of errors are about 0 so you get
the perfect solution this is an example
on the graph of Internet routers as of
2003 I download it from somewhere and so
it basically gets all them right you you
can so this was an example where you
take a shortest path on which is a
specific problem and your embedded in
this continuous flow and then you can
solve it very efficiently you can take
any other MVP Michael decision process
with discrete actions and you can embed
it in this continuous Samuel of problems
and then solve things there and then map
back so it's a little bit like linear
programming real sense relaxation in
integer programming fact it has very
similar properties drag the way you do
that is you saw some system of linear
equations that at each state and that's
sort of scale says order N and very fast
to solve and hear sound example so
here's some other grid worlds these are
the correct optimal values this is the
approximate once you get an r-squared
like 926 is another one this is some
sort of machine repair example so here
we have some machine intends to break
over time the state who knows how broken
it is
time you can choose to repair it so the
actions are going to push this thing
down but you peg cost for repairs so
there's some optimal value function this
tower approximation and the poster to
get out the approximation is basically
within one percent of the optimal so
it's a good thing the last thing I'll
show you is that i don't think i'm going
to show these equations but basically
you can now take this idea and transform
it into a continuous setting and the way
you do that is first we're going to
replace our discrete state space with a
euclidean space RM okay and we're going
to define some passive dynamics in
discrete time but continuous state okay
so that's that's trib you just replace
all the sounds with integrals nothing
magic happens so the bellman equation
that we had before it becomes dislike
this kind of thing and then what you
have to do is you have to take a
continuous time limit very carefully
okay and you use sticks from stochastic
calculus do that and you rearrange this
equation and basically what you get is
the following so you can have a
continuous system where the state has
some passive dynamics you can be
nonlinear whatever you want and then it
has some noise so that's the passive
dynamic so it's a it's a nonlinear
diffusion process okay and then you
define this linear differential operator
which is the Doppler between this
passive dynamics and the gradient of the
function you're looking for and then
this one half of the Hessian and
diffusion coefficient so this is very
standard thing that you get from Ito's
calculus and stochastic differential
equations it's called generator of the
process you can think of it as a
expected value of the directional
derivative of Z under that fact that
that's precisely what it computes but
importantly it's a linear operator right
so if I have z plus z prime it's just
going to add its derivative Selenia okay
so if we were to go through this map
which we want you get the following
result so the op the exponential
transformed optimal value function for
nonlinear diffusions has this form so
these are different formulations you
basically get a linear operator minus
the state costs times the value function
and that has to be go to something so
this is this is easy this is an
eigenvalue problem this is a backwards
in time recursion in the discounted cost
again you get something nonlinear but
the rest of it looks very much like it
now so it's important to realize that if
you're solving a partial differential
equation the fact that it's linear
doesn't mean you've solved it because we
can it is linear in the function Z that
you're looking for but it's still
nonlinear in the state of the system
however this kind of second order linear
differential equations are very well
studied because most the most of the
laws of physics are expressed in that
form and businesses have developed very
powerful numerical techniques for
solving them and we can now take
advantage of them and apply them to
solving stochastic control problems this
is the problem that you'll end up
solving so so this is the control
dynamics and the cost function turns out
to be something I depends on the state
plus this quadratic energy so the Kelda
versions that we defined in the discrete
case ends up being exactly the quadratic
energy costs for the continuous systems
and that's because the kale diversions
between gaussians issues the squared
distance between their means so there's
nothing magic about them so we can use
that to approximate continuous process
at least occur on the hill thing this
little car wants to go there this is the
optimal value function computed with
policy iteration this is what we get the
control policy will get is just the same
so this is the CPU time this is how good
is the solution we find so this new
method is this these are the best
possible dynamic programming methods you
can get so we're about ten times faster
than the best possible dynamic
programming and the problem we're
solving is is there other general
problem right so again any
nonlinearities you won't hear the
constraints are that the control has to
enter this thing in a linear way but
that's usually the case for most
physical systems the noise has to ask in
the control space and the cost function
has to have this separate quadratic
energy thing but this can be whatever it
was
last thing I'll mention is this so when
you have a linear PDE that takes us back
to the issue of motive synergies that we
talked about earlier so if you have a
linear equation you know that the
solutions can be composed linearly okay
and that's very convenient if you want
to build something like most images or
motor primitives or some building blocks
that can be recombined to give you new
solutions and so so suppose I have a
problem where I have some dynamical
system and it's going to hit some
boundary condition and that's when the
movement ends I'm going to have some
final costs over the boundary let's I'm
going to move to this table and when I
hit the table i'm going to measure the
distance from my finger to some target
okay and i can put the target at
different places so the target can you
need to be censored your regular thing
okay so now i can solve the problem
multiple times for different final costs
and suppose i get the solutions to this
well now what I'm doing is I'm solving
the same linear PDE with different
boundary conditions and I know that if I
were to combine the boundary conditions
linearly then the solutions which is
going to combine linearly in the same
way and so therefore I get a very
straightforward way for composing
optimal control laws to get new optimal
control laws for different problems it's
a huge illustration here's a simple
point mass this is position this is time
control which is very simple we want the
final final cost could be a quadratic
that can be centered somewhere so this
is this known as a linear quadratic
optimal control problem if you have if
the final cost isn't either quadratic
like this then we know how to solve this
sort of in closed form using the riccati
equations get two linear feedback
control law looks like this and then you
get some histogram of final stage which
is a gas now we can combine two of those
in closed form without doing any further
optimization and now i can solve things
like that so here now i have two of
these final costs and it asks me to do
some bite by model thing it says go
either here or here but not in the
middle or i could have combined them in
some other way and do that whatever
shape of my cost function i want okay so
now we can solve not only these kinds of
things but also things that look like
that and this is a closed form solution
based
so it's very promising in terms of being
able to find primitives for optimal
control and and combine them and we're
hoping to explore that one okay I should
really end here thank you for listening
so the which I've said it's not a pond
deep it is an MVP there is no
uncertainty about the state here if you
put as necessity about the state things
become more complicated I mean we've
done a little bit of that so there's one
slide that I skipped where we're doing
that so here we are where it's at sign
here we're looking at people are moving
around and they have to both tracks on
target and learn how the mapping from
this position sensor to the screen works
and that mapping is drifting so there's
a certainty so what we're doing is we're
building a common filter to attract to
model the estimator and then we're
taking the mean and covariance of the
common filter and embedding them into a
plant dynamics so now instead of having
a partially observable low dimensional
system we now have a fully observable
high dimensional system which has been
augmented with the common filter
dynamics basically and now we can apply
this method in so that's one way another
way to do it is to just build your best
estimated treat it as if it was real and
and proceed I mean pungi pizza you know
let's go very badly and you can't deal
with things that have more than like a
hundred states are sent and here we're
giving so for example these
discretizations i showed you for this
carb on a hill thing this this has close
to a million discrete States so you can
depandi be sorry well you can attempt
but it's not clear what the hair is out
is going to be how could you know
okay so that yeah that's not bad I mean
still they did this is like 10 seconds
at what point basement so some sort of
practical filtered estimating the status
of it is okay yeah so occur to me
putting a certainty in this is is
important but but I mean what you're
asking has had people tried to use
discrete sort of MVPs to solve
continuous problems and yessir is very
rarely so people so for example rest
steady rate at MIT did this bipedal
locomotion thing with reinforcement
learning that sounds great but actually
what he did is he did most of it by hand
and then the reinforcement learning was
optimizing some very low dimensionals or
abstract control things so it's not
really like giving with a nonlinear
dynamics so basically control suffers
from the curse of dimensionality now
when the dimensionality of the state
space increases the size of the good
that you need to put on your scales
exponentially so that basically if you
can do it so you have to use various
function approximation methods but
that's really hiding the problem under
the hood because you're still operating
over space which is exponentially large
and you don't know a priori what the
solution is so if you have to to
consider all possibilities Daniel screw
with these when you turn the thing into
a linear PG they're they're amazingly
efficient methods that you can do so so
one of them is based on the Feynman cash
theorem which says that the solution to
this second order linear PDE is can be
obtained by sampling from the passive
dynamics so in fact when physicists
solve high dimensional PD is that often
that's often one of the problems so you
start somewhere and you let the thing to
sample from the passive dynamics in you
accumulate the cost of along the way and
that's guaranteed to converge to the
answer to to the PD and you can speed
that up with important sampling so this
really opens up new man so you can use
sir ian provide for your methods or
various basis function so for example if
you have a linear TV and your time to
approximate the solution with the basis
function so
some basis set and you use the linear
function approximator the PD gives you a
linear algebraic equations for your
coefficients and if the basis functions
has a finite support the level to the
small like gaussians for example then
that system becomes very sparse so you
can throw in for hundreds of thousands
or millions of basis functions and then
you're solving a very large starts
system and that's something we know how
to handle so being linear is is a good
thing I haven't yet taken advantage of
this food I mean has taken me more than
a year to develop the map but now we're
beginning to exploit the numerical
methods that you can develop based on
thank you